- WHEN SHE DOES TALK,
LIKE, YOU'RE LISTENING.
, OH, MY GOD.
LAST TIME, I WAS LIKE,
"WHO ARE YOU?
YOU'RE BRILLIANT."
- I KNOW.
- [gasps] OH, MY GOD!
- [gasps]
OH, MY GOD.
both: OH, MY GOD!
- AMY, LOOK AT THAT ONE!
- OH, MEGAN!
- HE IS SO CUTE.
- THAT IS
THE CUTEST F-ING PUPPY
I'VE EVER SEEN
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
- OH, MY GOD,
I'M JUST GONNA TAKE HIM,
AND I JUST WANNA BITE
HIS LITTLE EARS OFF.
- I JUST WANNA TAKE
HIS LITTLE LEGS,
AND I COULD SNACK ON 'EM
LIKE CHICKEN DRUMETTES.
- YEAH, I JUST WANNA TAKE
HIS FUZZY LITTLE PERFECT HEAD.
I WANNA PUT IT IN MY MOUTH
AND SQUEEZE DOWN ON IT HARD
UNTIL I HAVE A PUPPY FACE
DIAMOND IN MY MOUTH.
- MM, I FEEL LIKE I HAVE
TO WRAP HIS FACE IN A TOWEL
AND THEN BEAT IT
WITH A TIRE IRON.
- I'M GOING TO BUY THAT DOG,
I'M GOING DRIVE HIM TO THE VET,
AND I'M GOING TO HAVE HIM
PUT DOWN IMMEDIATELY.
- [gasps]
OH, MY GOD.
YOU WHAT I'M GONNA HAVE TO DO?
- WHAT?
- I'M GONNA HAVE TO TAKE
THAT SCRUFFY LITTLE NOSE...
- YES.
- AND JUST KICK IT.
I JUST HAVE TO--
- YES.
- I WOULD KICK IT
UNTIL IT COMES UP ON MY SHOES
LIKE LITTLE PUPPY
SNOUT SLIPPERS.
AND THEN I'M GONNA GO
TO A PARTY AND EVERYONE'S LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD, WHERE'D YOU
GET THOSE SLIPPERS?"
I'LL BE LIKE, "THESE ARE
MY FACE SLIPPERS
FROM MY ADORABLE,
DUMB LITTLE PUPPY."
- THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
I WAS GOING TO SAY!
- ESP!
- OH, MY GOD, I JUST WANNA
TAKE HIS HEAD.
I WANNA PEEL THE SKIN
OFF OF HIS SKULL.
- I KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
- I WANNA JUST START THROWING IT
UP LIKE PIZZA DOUGH.
UNTIL IT'S LONG, FLAT,
AND ROUND.
I WANNA TAKE IT TO A PICNIC AND
TOSS IT AROUND LIKE A FRISBEE
AT A PUPPY-FACE-FRISBEE
PICNIC!
- LET'S GET HIM!
- YEAH!
- SO CUTE.
OH, MY GOD,
IS IT ME,
OR IS IT LIKE TOTALLY
MOSQUITO-Y OUT HERE?
- OH, MY GOD,
REMEMBER THIS ONE?
HE WAS SO CUTE.
- SO CUTE.